- You've seen my next
guest in many, many shows,
including "Insatiable", "Shameless",
"Mad TV" and "Orange is the New Black".
She has a new book out now.
It's called "Little Miss Little Compton".
Give it up for Arden Myrin y'all.
(audience applause)
(upbeat music)
- Hi!
- Love your whole outfit.
- I picked it out for you.
- It makes me happy.
- You know, this was
like a big outing for me.
I have fake hair in.
I have fake eyelashes.
- I have too.
- I had to, you know,
I've been in my little pandemic hole
so this felt so exciting to
dress up to come see you.
- I know, everybody that's
actually come to the show,
that's the first thing they say.
They're like, so I put on a bra.
- Oh my god, I have a bra.
I mean, truly it's been, it's so exciting.
You're like the first
person I've hung out with.
- Oh my gosh, aim higher first of all.
But no, I love your outfit.
It's so shiny-
- Thank you.
- And it makes me happy.
- And I'm sorry Potato the
cat couldn't be with us today.
This was the last time,
everybody take a look,
when she was here.
- Oh my God, you guys, oh my God.
(cat meowing)
- Now, you can't have Potato.
- Oh my god, Potato's everything I want.
- Oh, well, he wants you too, sorry.
- Oh my God, it's destiny.
Okay, I'm not even lying.
I bring up, I think not adopting Potato
was my biggest regret from 2019.
(laughing)
It was the biggest mistake
I've made all year.
- You could have had Potato
this whole quarantine
to snuggle with.
- Oh my God, can you imagine?
I would have been like, thank you.
I get like nine months
straight with Potato.
- And I always get so worried
when they have animals on
this show, like to adopt
because I am, I mean,
I'm my mother's child.
Like I grew up and I'm like,
I have to take them all.
- Me too, I have four animals already.
So it's like, maybe it's best for
Potato.
- Potato's sake.
- Potato might've been too small to fend
the rest of them off.
- To fend for herself.
- Yeah, I would have been passed over.
- Well, how have you been
keeping yourself entertained
these past months?
- Well, I have to say, in
between giving myself haircuts,
which to varying degrees
of success-
- Oh you're brave.
- I did three haircuts.
I actually started doing
a very cool, sexy hobby.
I've taken up jigsaw puzzling.
- I'm currently working
on a Golden Girls one
that my friends gave me.
- [Arden] Oh my god, are you serious?
- I'm totally not kidding.
- I love jigsaw puzzles.
I like ones, I don't like elegant ones.
I like sort of like a fun sort of trashy-
- Like Golden Girls.
I actually started designing,
I designed my own puzzle.
This was a puzzle that I designed.
I don't know-
- I wanna see your puzzle.
- This is my "Meet the Authors".
It's me and my cat Mittens.
Can you imagine Mittens
and Potato hanging out?
Mittens has some, I'll put it here?
- I know we can't maybe touch it.
They've probably sterilized it, I'm sure.
- I wiped it down with a wipe myself.
I recreated my sixth grade photo.
I had braces made and
that's Mittens the cat
and it's a "Meet the Authors" photo.
- This is amazing, first of all.
I wanna make-
- Thank you so much.
- This is like a thing.
I wanna make a really
goofy picture like this
and have it be our show theme
that we give out his presents.
- I'm not gonna lie.
When you realize you can
actually make a custom puzzle
it's a game changer.
When you're like, wait a minute,
you're telling me I can have a photograph
and then make it a jigsaw puzzle?
- Yes, and make it like your old kid ones.
Your actual real ones,
where there were lasers in the background
and like the two heads.
- You think that is not going to be made
for every holiday gift this year?
I've got time on my hand
and I've got access to the internet.
That's what's happening.
(laughing)
- I know, we're all ordering everything.
So wait, the last time you were here,
you told me you were working on a book
and you weren't lying.
- I wrote a whole book!
- You did!
- I wrote "Little Miss Little Compton"
- It's so great.
So "Little Miss Little Compton", a memoir.
So I mean, what's it about?
Obviously its a memoir.
- It's a memoir.
It's a book, I grew up
in this little tiny town
called Little Compton, Rhode Island,
that's never even heard
of the real other Compton.
I mean, it's like the tiniest, tiniest,
like lobstermen and fishermen,
and I was just like,
I had stars in my eyes
and it's so small.
Did you know that stealing
mail is a federal crime, Kelly?
- I did actually.
- Well, I didn't know that
until somebody started
stealing mail in our town and
they were like on the case.
Like who's stealing all the mail.
The culprit was, they
found out it was a pet crow
that a woman had named Poe the Crow
who was flying around,
stealing all the mail.
Just because you're a
bird, it doesn't mean you
can't get arrested.
They put crow on house arrest
and he became an indoor crow
for the rest of his life.
- The craziest part is
that if actually she
trained the crow to do that.
That's the deeper story there.
- She's like, fly over to the marine house
and see what kind of mail they're getting.
- See if anyone got
any cash for Christmas.
- If she did, that would make
me even love it even more.
- I know you're like, free the crow.
- Free the crow, you guys.
- You kept it like
daytime with your mouth.
- I did, I did, I really did.
- So how did your family
end up in a Little Compton
'cause they weren't
originally from there, right?
- No, they were from New York city,
so it was sort of a
strange place to end up.
But my parents, they met at work.
There they are.
They're recreating the
"American Gothic" photo.
So my dad looked like John Belushi.
- [Kelly] I totally see
where you get your humor.
I love your family.
- When they decided to
have kids my dad said,
"I'll do it in one of two places,
"Manhattan or this tiny town called
Little Compton, Rhode Island"
and my mom picked the road less traveled
and that's where the book starts.
- Oh my God, I love this.
It's like a movie.
- It's like a movie, but it was fun.
I mean, it was this quirky
household that I grew up in.
- I love, the photo says it all.
I grew up in a small town as well.
Like what was the biggest
challenge for you?
- I mean, I don't know
if you guys tend to,
I have so much hair, like
the "Mad TV" hair department
said I could wig a village.
(laughing)
So, and `we only had a general store,
we didn't even have a grocery store
so they didn't even have hair conditioner.
It was just like cream rinse, you know.
Look at that, look at that.
Look at that hair, look at me.
I was a ginger.
I was like a helmet.
- Oh my god.
- Look at how confident.
Look at the size of my head
versus that other little girl,
like, look how calm , I
was so the alpha in that.
- [Kelly] Well first of
all, you're in front of her,
so she's in the back, yeah.
- She's in front but like-
- You're in the foreground.
- But so I couldn't be, so my mom-
- I'm gonna be honest with you,
that might be one of my favorite haircuts
I've ever seen on a kid (laughs).
- Look how confident,
look at my pants, like,
look at the, like, am I still in a diaper?
What's happening with the pleats?
- [Kelly] It's awesome.
- So, my mom, there was only
on place to get your hair cut
in town and it was at Jimmy the Barber
who cut the cops and
the lobstermens' hair.
So I would get the boys,
like helmet or like buzz cut.
And I looked like Barb
from "Stranger Things"
until I was like 15.
- But I hear, this is unfortunate,
so your mama passed right
before the book came out.
- She did.
It was actually sort of bittersweet.
You know, I've been trying
to sell this book for years
and she was so funny and so magical
and she died suddenly last March.
- So sorry.
- Oh my God, thank you but
like the gift of it was
I was on the way to the funeral
and I got this email that said,
hope you're having a great day.
We can't wait to do this book with you.
I sold it on the way to her funeral.
I had literally been trying for years
and she was barely in the proposal.
And then like now I felt
like it was her book
and my friend read it and she
goes, it's not your memoir,
it's your mom-oir.
And she was so funny and
I feel like I gave her
this funny book that sort of honoring
everything that she gave
to my brother and I.
- Yeah,
(audience applause)
and wow, you're an optimistic.
Like, to turn that around, that's amazing.
- Yeah, oh my God.
- Well Arden's book is called
"Little Miss Little Compton".
Y'all got to go buy it.